Every year, Netflix ups the game with its
original content.
In fact, the streaming service will soon boast
1,000 original movies and shows in its library.
You'll probably never be able to watch them
all, but there's no denying that there's truly
something for everyone available.
The company is already hard at work putting
out tantalizing glimpses of their 2019 lineup.
From a gangster film by Martin Scorsese to
a brand new superhero series, 2019 is shaping
up to be an epic year.
Here's a look at everything we know about
the 2019 Netflix originals that are sure to
blow you away.
The Irishman
Barely five years ago, it would have been
insane to suggest that Martin Scorsese would
direct a direct-to-streaming feature.
But now that video-on-demand services are
backing Oscar-winning films like Amazon's
Manchester by the Sea, it's safe to say that
the landscape has changed.
And with Netflix willing to dump billions
in the pot for new original content, who can
blame Scorsese for working out a production
deal?
The result sees the Goodfellas director going
back to his roots with The Irishman, a mob
epic starring Robert De Niro as Frank Sheeran,
the hitman allegedly responsible for the disappearance
of Jimmy Hoffa.
De Niro isn't the only big name attached:
Al Pacino is on board to play Hoffa, with
Joe Pesci, Harvey Keitel, and Anna Paquin
co-starring.
The Central Park Five
With the hard-hitting documentary 13th, Ava
DuVernay proved beyond a shadow of a doubt
that she could handle sensitive, real-life
struggles in a way that resonated with Netflix's
audience.
So it should come as no surprise that the
streaming service is tapping her for an in-depth
dive into one of the most infamous crimes
of the '80s.
In 1989, New Yorker Trisha Meili was jogging
in Central Park when she was assaulted.
Police subsequently arrested five teenagers,
who were convicted and sentenced to prison.
It wasn't until over a decade later that the
real perpetrator confessed, proving the five
young men to be innocent.
The Central Park Five will be a scripted drama
series that explores the aftermath of the
crime, from the media circus surrounding the
trials to the young men's eventual release
from prison.
It should offer an emotional look into how
the case affected the lives of everyone involved.
Sex Education
One of the bright spots of 2019 should be
Gillian Anderson's return to the small screen,
after leaving both The X-Files and American
Gods.
She's slated to star in Sex Education as Jean,
a therapist and working mom who's trying her
best to raise her son, Otis, who's a bit of
an odd duck.
He's a virgin who knows more about getting
busy than any of his sheet-shaking classmates.
Asa Butterfield, who you may know from Ender's
Game, stars as Otis, and the series is slated
for a tentative 2019 release date.
The Last Dance
In the '90s, there was only one name that
mattered in basketball: Michael Jordan.
As the scoreboard-stacking star of the Chicago
Bulls, Jordan became both an athletic legend
and a pop culture icon.
He brought whole stadiums to their feet with
his buzzer beaters and rim-rattling dunks.
With The Last Dance, Netflix is teaming up
with ESPN to deliver a one-of-a-kind look
at the sports climate of the early '90s, when
Air Jordan soared to stardom.
The 10-part documentary series will combine
interviews with Jordan and his former teammates
along with archival footage of the Bulls'
final bid for one more championship in 1998.
Put it all together, and it should be a unique,
enthralling experience for any sports fan.
Polar
From Bond villain to cannibal genius, Mads
Mikkelsen has practically done it all, which
is why it's almost surprising that he's found
yet another exceptionally unique project to
tackle.
Netflix's upcoming Polar is based on Polar:
Came from the Cold, a graphic novel that follows
a retired assassin who's forced back into
his old ways after an attempt on his life.
The concept began life as a webcomic before
Dark Horse picked it up and turned it into
a graphic novel, and it's about as crazy as
you'd expect.
From its hyper violence to its bleak, neo-noir
trappings, Polar: Came from the Cold is certainly
an experience, and we're hoping the film finds
a way to capture that insanity.
Mikkelsen is taking the lead role, with Vanessa
Hudgens and Katheryn Winnick signed on to
co-star.
Raising Dion
In 2015, writer and director Dennis Liu wrote
and released a comic book series called Raising
Dion, accompanied by a trailer to promote
it.
The comic follows a single mother who realizes
that her seven-year-old son Dion is developing
superpowers.
It's a unique, completely different type of
superhero story than many people are used
to, and the first issue snagged plenty of
fans.
It didn't take long for Netflix to take notice,
ordering a ten-episode series with Liu at
the helm.
The series will follow the same story as the
comic, with Alisha Wainwright starring as
Dion's mother, and Michael B. Jordan as her
husband.
In a climate filled with superheroes of all
shapes and forms, Raising Dion definitely
looks like an original take on the genre.
"Dion!
You better not be naked up there again!"
Dolemite is My Name
Eddie Murphy has flown way under the radar
for the past several years, so it's big news
that he's set to appear in a new project.
In Dolemite is My Name, he stars as Rudy Ray
Moore, a comedian and actor best known for
starring in the 1975 exploitation film Dolemite.
Moore had a long, varied career in both standup
and the film industry, so there really isn't
a better actor to bring him to life.
The supporting cast is just as star-studded,
with Wesley Snipes, T.I., and Keegan-Michael
Key all set to appear.
Even Chris Rock was spotted on-set, decked
out in the kind of outfit that could've only
come from the '70s.